nos preguntan el teorema del valor medio
es aplicable para h en el intervalo y
nos dan varias opciones de intervalos
aquí que debemos considerar por separado
esta es la gráfica de igual a hdx y como
siempre los invito a que pausa en el
vídeo y traten de ver si el teorema del
valor medio es aplicable para alguna o
para varias opciones de intervalos
resolvamos estos juntos si no están
familiarizados con el teorema del valor
medio les recomiendo que vean el vídeo
de introducción al teorema del valor
medio o al vídeo de introducción al
teorema de existencia en khan academy
pero como repaso para quienes estamos
familiarizados con estos teoremas
recordemos que las condiciones cuando
tenemos un intervalo cerrado de a a b la
función debe ser diferenciable en el
intervalo abierto de aa b
y ser continua en el intervalo cerrado
de haber otra forma de ver esto es que
si la función es diferenciable en el
intervalo también será continua por lo
que la segunda condición es para
asegurarse de que la función también es
continua en los puntos extremos si se
cumplen ambas condiciones vamos a hacer
un dibujo para visualizar mejor lo que
nos dice el teorema del valor medio esta
es nuestra función aquí tenemos aquí
tenemos ven y suponemos que se cumplen
estas condiciones el teorema del valor
medio nos dice que va a existir un valor
en x que llamaremos c dentro de este
intervalo el que incluso podría estar en
los extremos para el cual la derivada de
c será igual a la tasa de cambio
promedio de a ave la pendiente de la
recta secante es la tasa de cambio
promedio y visualmente podríamos decir
que en este punto la pendiente de su
recta tangente será igual aquí tenemos
la c que nos dice el teorema en este
vídeo no vamos a encontrar los puntos es
pues solamente nos preguntan si podemos
aplicar el teorema del valor medio en
esto
veamos las opciones la primera opción es
el intervalo cerrado de menos 5 a menos
1 lo ubicamos en la gráfica la función
es diferenciable en este intervalo
abierto bueno tenemos esta
discontinuidad aquí que no es
diferenciable sino es continuo no puede
ser diferenciable por lo que esto
inválida estas dos condiciones así que
para esta primera opción la respuesta es
no el teorema del valor medio no aplica
en este intervalo el segundo intervalo
es menos 1 a 3 vamos a ponerlo en otro
color si nos fijamos en la función en
este intervalo cerrado podemos ver que
la función es una recta continua por lo
que es diferenciable y continua en este
intervalo por lo que tiene sentido que
aquí se aplique el teorema del valor
medio de hecho cualquier sé en este
intervalo tendrá la derivada igual a la
tasa de cambio promedio instantánea
definitivamente en este intervalo si
aplica el teorema del valor medio ahora
veamos el intervalo cerrado de 3 a 7 al
ver la función en este intervalo cerrado
vemos
que es continua por lo que cumple con la
segunda condición pero es diferenciable
una buena forma de identificar un punto
que es continuo pero no diferenciables
es este de acá donde vemos estos bordes
que forman una esquina pues aquí no
tenemos bien definida la pendiente de la
recta tangente en este punto podría ser
ésta o podría ser esta otra así que como
no puede ser diferenciable en este punto
cuando x es igual a 6 no puede ser
diferenciable en este intervalo abierto
de 3 a 7 por lo que no aplica el
problema del valor medio podemos ver
esto en la gráfica la tasa de cambio
promedio entre los extremos de nuestro
intervalo viéndola como la recta se
cante es esta que dibujamos aquí y no
vemos algún punto en este intervalo cuya
tasa de cambio instantánea o la
pendiente de su recta tangente sea igual
a la pendiente de la recta secante
entre los puntos límites de nuestro
intervalo así que no aplica el teorema
del valor medio veamos el último
intervalo de menos 3 a 2
lo dibujamos si vemos el intervalo
abierto de menos 3 a 2 sin considerar lo
que
ocurre en menos tres y en menos dos en
el intervalo abierto parece que es
diferenciable y continua pero sin duda
no es continua en el intervalo cerrado
pues en -3 la función no es continua
debido a esto no aplica el teorema del
valor medio de hecho podemos observar
que no aplica porque al ver la pendiente
de la recta secante entre los puntos
límites en este intervalo que estoy
dibujando podemos ver que en este
intervalo no hay punto alguno
donde la pendiente de la recta tangente
o la pendiente instantánea o la derivada
sea igual a la pendiente de la recta
secante esto no viola el teorema del
valor medio porque este problema no
aplica aquí no cumple la condición de
ser continua en el intervalo cerrado y
con esto terminamos